When you are in a position of leadership in
a kitchen or even if you are not being patient
it’s something that is very important.
If you are a beginner in the kitchen and you
have to learn craftsmanship you have to be
patient, because you’re not born with knife
skills.
You’re not born knowing how to roast a chicken
or cook carrots.
It’s something that you want to learn, and
it’s going to be very repetitive, and you
cannot get frustrated.
You have to be very patient.
If you are in a position of leadership in
a kitchen you have to be very patient as well,
because you are basically teaching the team
to accomplish your vision.
And if you are not patient they are going
to be potentially scared of you and therefore
someone who’s shaking like that will not
be doing a better job than someone who’s
confident.
Then maybe if you may create frustration in
them you may create many negative thoughts
in your team.
So patience in the kitchen it’s something
that is very important of course.
When I was young my mother remarried and my
stepfather Hugo – in the book his name is
Hugo because his real name is something else.
But Hugo is very mean to me as a young kid
and he bullies me when my mother is not around.
The way he does it it’s obviously very vicious
and when I come back home from my day in school
he’s testing me and he’s trying to make
me angry and to make me fight with him.
And, of course, he’s an adult and he’s
much stronger than I am.
And then I was trying to keep my cool and
I was trying to not ignore him but to rationalize
a little bit.
Maybe he was jealous.
Maybe something was wrong.
And suddenly I would explode and I would scream
at him or I would break things that he likes
or we would fight.
And as soon as I would do that I was the loser
and he was the winner because that’s what
he wanted.
He wanted to basically destabilize the young
kid that I was.
Many times I had the pleasure to win the fights
but fighting is already losing so what I learned
about responding to people who try to bully
is that soon as you respond they got you.
They got what they wanted.
You’re the bad person.
I believe that violence will attract violence
and a compassionate approach will have more
chances to get in return some compassionate
answer.
And if you are talking about world leaders—although
I believe the world is very complicated and
it’s not my expertise, I’m a chef—But
I think that using wisdom will definitely
be much better than enticing violence.
By responding with armies and worse to terrorist
attacks creates a system of no end in violence.
So I am a strong believer of nonviolence,
and I think it’s good that I am in a kitchen
and not at the White House.